suivant la tradition la commission des
finances s'est saisi pour avis du projet
de loi de financement rectificatif de la
sécurité sociale pour devenir23 a émis
un avis favorable à son adoption le
vendredi 30 janvier au terme d'une
journée qui aura permis de distinguer
d'un côté celles et ceux qui d'entre
nous comme le gouvernement sont attachés
à la protection et à la hausse du niveau
de vie de nos retraités à la répartition
juste de l'effort des actifs mais
surtout à la préservation de notre
système de retraite par répartition et
de l'autre celles et ceux qui sont prêts
à mettre en danger le service des
pensions voir à réduire leur montant qui
considèrent le travail comme une
aliénation comme une aliénation dont on
ne guérirait comme interdisant aux
entreprises de réussir et qui préfèrent
faire financer les retraites par la
dette qui pèse de plus en plus sur les
générations futures au regard du rapport
du corps dans l'ensemble des scénariés
présentés nous ferons face à un déficit
de financement au cours des années à
venir selon l'hypothèse centrale retenue
par le gouvernement ce déficit atteindra
0,5 points de PIB en 2040 puis 08 en
2070 sur les 10 prochaines années ce
sont 150 milliards de déficits cumulés
que nous risquons or un système de
retraite pour tenir ses promesses
vis-à-vis des retraités d'aujourd'hui et
de demain se doit d'être équilibré le
refuser cette hypothéquer l'avenir je
tiens ici à écarter certaines
propositions il réalistes ou démagogie
non on ne peut pas fonder le
rétablissement des comptes de
l'assurance vieillesse sur les recettes
fluctuantes comme les bénéfices ou les
dividendes mais oui c'est en réduisant
le coût du travail que l'on soutient
l'emploi que l'on renforce la
compétitivité et que l'on augmente les
recettes preuve est faite depuis 2017
non on ne peut pas redescendre l'âge de
départ à la retraite à 60 ans notre
démographie très défavorable interdit
tout retour en arrière alors que nous
comptions dans les années 90 trois
actifs pour en recrute pour un retraité
nous en avons actuellement 1,7 pour un
retraité et prochainement 1,5 actifs
pour un retraité niait l'évidence
revient à mentir aux Français
quelques mots à présent sur le périmètre
de la loi de finances crypto sensum le
solde 2023 serait un léger recul à moins
7,5 milliards d'euros en raison de la
mise en oeuvre des mesures de
revalorisation et d'amélioration le
déficit serait ramené dès 2026 à 12,3
milliards contre 15,700 la réforme et la
trajectoire envisagée devrait conduire à
l'équilibre de notre système de retraite
mesure sociale incluse d'ici 2030 nous
commençons donc ce jour chers collègues
l'examen d'un texte dont l'ambition est
bien l'équité et la solidarité entre les
générations ainsi il est proposé
d'affilier les prochains personnels de
cinq régimes spéciaux au régime général
j'ai entendu dire qu'il ne concernait
que 2% des actifs c'est exact mais leur
déficit concerne en revanche 100% des
Français qui les finances en
responsabilité pour garantir que notre
système demeure parmi les plus
redistributifs il est indispensable de
reculer de deux ans de manière
progressive l'âge d'ouverture des droits
et d'accélérer l'allongement durée de
cotisations actées par la réforme
Touraine ce projet je l'ai dit tiens
compte des inégalités de la vie et vise
de sans pouvoir toutes les réparer à les
atténuer c'est pour cette raison qui
revalorisé le minimum contributif qui
est relevez le plancher de récupération
sur succession de la location de
solidarité personnes âgées ou qui est
instauré un départ anticipé pour les
travailleurs inaptes parmi les nouveaux
droits ouverts notons que le cumul entre
l'emploi et la retraite génèrent
désormais des droits et une hausse des
pensions nous créons également une
assurance vieillesse pour les aidants
les trimestres validés au titre de
l'assurance vieillesse du parent au
foyer seront désormais comptabilisés
pour le bénéfice du minimum contributif
et de la retraite anticipée pour
carrière longue alors je souhaite bon
courage à celles et ceux qui voteront la
motion de rejet et iront sur le terrain
expliqué qu'il refuse d'emblée les
avancées proposées
enfin en tant que femme
en tant que femme je voudrais démentir
le fait que cette réforme nous soit
défavorable l'intégration de trimestres
parents au foyer dans la durée cotisée
pour bénéficier d'un départ anticipé
pour carrière longue nous concernera en
priorité l'inclusion de ces trimestres à
VPF dans le calcul du micro permettra
plus de femmes de mes déficit de la
hausse des minimas de pension et c'est
amélioration sera nettement plus marquée
pour nous comme la démontrer l'étude
d'impact la prise en compte des périodes
passées en tube pour le calcul de la
retraite concernera en majorité les
femmes et enfin la création de
l'allocation vieillesse et danse
appliquera davantage à nous pour
terminer et parce que les mesures de ce
texte engagent l'avenir j'appelle de mes
vœux l'inclusion d'une clause de
revoyure permettant d'évaluer les
impacts financiers et sociaux de la
réforme ami parcours un amendement était
adopté en ce sens par la commission des
finances et j'espère qu'il en sera de
même en séance mes chers collègues je
crois que les deux marques de just
s'agit d'un système de retraite par
répartition sont son équilibre financier
et son traitement équitable des
situations individuelles les plus
difficiles